if you follow me you know i'm an
optimistic positive dude and i really am
and i i i i
i'm an arms wide open guy i like people
to get together you know and so i always
look for a silver lining in dark days
and look this past year or whatever has
been [ __ ] terrible for everybody but
for me the silver lining was this i have
older kids and if you have older kids
you know
that
you hit that time where you're like oh
[ __ ] wait i'm not going to see you every
day yeah
right
and then and so this year
this year they had to come home
so it was like a bonus year with my kids
so for me that was like a silver lining
you know
and um
[Applause]
but it was also a stark reminder about
how how much smarter my daughter is than
my son like
anybody got teenage boys in here
then you know that laugh
[Music]
i mean teenage boys are the dumbest
[ __ ] walking
[Music]
like that's the dumbest sound that can
come out of a human's mouth
and by the way you can tell how dumb
like
like teenage boys are so dumb
any guys in here under the age of 25
yeah you ever all you dudes oh
but like young men don't care about the
quality of their lives
quantity
quantity if they something say something
stupid and you don't believe it they're
like well here's something else dumbo
okay here you go
let me tell you the dumbest lie jacob
wolf ever told me
this one is so ridiculously dumb
he was driving himself to school he was
a senior in high school on a tuesday so
it was eight in the morning
and um
the school calls at 10.
he's like jacob's late and i go okay
so he comes home and i go hey man he
goes yo
and he said school
said you were late and he goes yeah i
was
i go why were you late he goes oh yeah i
was driving to school i got stuck behind
a parade i was like
[Applause]
honestly like i don't know how parades
work you know what i mean like
and i asked him on a tuesday on the way
to school he was like yeah i thought it
was pretty weird too yeah
[Applause]
now
my daughter
way better liar i think it takes a
little bit of intelligence to be a good
liar you know
and so i feel like look
she this is how i knew she was gonna be
a great liar guys when she was seven
i walked into her room
i found her by herself in front of a
mirror practicing crying what
[Applause]
i walked out of there and i turned to my
wife i go hey you know whoever marries
her is [ __ ]
[Applause]
she's developing life skills at seven
years old
you know little boys in unit seven at
seven years old little boys are
literally pushing their dicks into their
bodies
[Applause]
just to see how long it'll stay there
that's the whole game
[Applause]
little girls are figuring out how to
take over the world
and little boys are like my dick's like
a turtle
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]